[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAMY HASSANEIN:
Thanks for joining us.
And this is a session
on how BuzzFeed
builds a great user experience
using BigQuery and Looker.
I'm Ramy Hassanein, and
I'm a customer engineer
for the Google Cloud
team supporting BuzzFeed
And coming up shortly
will be Nick Hardy,
who's a senior business
analyst over at BuzzFeed, who's
going to kind of go through the
story of who BuzzFeed is-- not
that any of you don't
know who they are.
But kind of take you
through their journey
of heading onto
BigQuery, all the hiccups
that they went through, the
problems they were trying
to solve, where they are
today, and where they want
to go in the future as well.
And not forgetting, obviously,
what they are using and taking
advantage of with Looker.
So we'll have a Q&A
session at the end.
So please try to save any
of your questions for that.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Nick.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK HARDY: everybody.
Like Ramy said, I'm Nick Hardy.
I'm on the data science
team for BuzzFeed.
Thank you for the intro, and
thank you all for coming today.
So I'm going to be talking
to you guys a little bit
how we thought about
surfacing data to our users,
and why that's so important
to us as an organization.
So before I do that, I want
to just sort of set the stage
and talk about our work.
I'm sure a lot of you guys
are familiar with our content.
But I think a lot
of people don't
realize the breadth of the
type of work that we're doing,
and also all the platforms
that it lives on.
And I think that that's
really important for context
for the way we think
about our data problems.
So of course we have our
classic BuzzFeed content,
like the dress.
I'm sure you guys are
all team blue and black,
or white and gold.
We can talk about that after.
But we also have
our news content,
which actually recently
moved onto its own domain.
So that came with its own
set of fun challenges.
We have our newly launched
lifestyle vertical,
which is called As/Is.
And then we also have a
bunch of video content,
which lives on bunch
of different platforms.
Of course, Tasty,
quite big on Facebook.
A lot of people actually don't
realize that this is BuzzFeed,
but it is.
And then also things like Worth
It, which live on YouTube.
So that's actually kind of
a great segue into the way
that we think about our data,
and some of the problems
that we have to solve.
So I'm just going to give
you guys some quick stats so
you can understand sort of
the scale of the problem
that we're trying to solve.
So we get about 9 billion
monthly content views.
That's coming from all of
our different platforms.
That's BuzzFeed.com, that's
our apps, it's Facebook,
it's YouTube, it's
Instagram, it's Snapchat.
About 200 million monthly
unique visitors to BuzzFeed.com
specifically.
Tens of thousands of assets.
So we actually have
a unique problem,
taking all the statistics and
attaching them to metadata,
specifically for content that's
living on multiple platforms.
And data from at
least 20 platforms.
Now, because we're
a content company,
content analytics are kind of at
the center of everything we do.
And we actually
have really placed
a huge emphasis on making
the role not just of our data
science and analytics
team, but actually
everybody in the company,
and especially the people
who are making stuff.
So this is actually a slide that
I stole from our CEO, Jonah,
who has a really great
philosophy for the way
that he thinks
about these things.
We like to think about these
things in terms of the feedback
loops that we're creating.
So people who are making stuff
are at the center of everything
that we're doing, but they're
also pushing this content out
to all different places--
to our site, to our apps, to all
of these different distributed
platforms.
And what we get back in
return is data and learnings,
and also, if we're lucky,
sometimes some money.
But what that also means
is that our reality--
is that we're left
sort of grappling
with data coming in from all
of these different platforms.
And this is actually
just a sampling
of the different things
that we're working with.
But as you can imagine, we sort
of are stuck with this problem.
Things coming in different
formats, some stuff
is time series, some
stuff is aggregate.
So that's sort of the heart
of what we're trying to solve.
So, great segue to our problem.
As a data team, how
do we consolidate
all of this data in one place?
Make it easy for hundreds
of users with varying skill
sets to understand.
So of course we have data
scientists, analysts,
engineers looking at the stuff.
We also have content creators.
We also have people
in our business team.
So we have a really
broad spectrum
in terms of people's expertise
and comfort with data, which
actually creates a sort of
unique problem of its own
in terms of the way that we want
to display this stuff to users,
and how easy we need to make
it for them to understand.
And then, of course, how do
accomplish these first two
goals without putting an
enormous and continual burden
on our data and
engineering teams.
So that's actually going to be
a really central piece of what
I talk about today.
So how do we actually do it?
I'm going to say some things
today that will probably
make it easier said than done.
And I really want to emphasize
before I say any of those
that this was a
big process for us,
and it really took
a village in terms
of the number of people,
the number of teams,
that worked on it.
And I actually have a
number of my great teammates
sitting here in the
fourth row here.
So you can come
talk to us after.
So the first piece of this was
building a strong foundation.
And again, I'm going to
oversimplify a little bit here.
But what it really came down to
for us was one critical piece,
and that was really just getting
everything in the same place.
So for us, that was BigQuery.
Obviously, that's me presenting
a grossly oversimplified
version of what it
took to get there.
So I can talk a little bit
about the infrastructure
that we used to do that.
And if you guys have more
specific questions about this,
we can cover it more in Q&A,
or you can come find us after,
and I'd be happy to
sort of chat through it.
But basically,
what we ultimately
landed on is that in
order for this to work,
in order for us to
accomplish our goals,
we needed to funnel everything
through the same pipeline,
and land it in the same place.
Now, we're very
fortunate at BuzzFeed
that one of our
VPs of engineering
was one of the people
who coauthored NSQ.
So we had a great data
pipeline to sit on top of.
So everything runs through
there, and it lands in GCS,
and then ultimately
in BigQuery, which
is sort of what we
can use to surface it
back up to all of our users.
You'll see some internal tools
that we built in here as well.
I'll talk a little bit about
those but not too much.
And again, if you
have questions,
just come find us after.
We'd be happy to chat about it.
So once you have that
foundation in place,
you have all your
data in BigQuery,
now you have the real task ahead
of you of building the home
that your users are
going to live in.
And I like to think about
this in terms of building
with bricks and not
straw, because you're
trying to build
something that's going
to last for the long haul.
So when we thought
about this, we sort of
knew that we had two big groups
that we were building for.
One was going to
be the data team,
and then the other was
going to be the users.
So I want to sort of talk
about those in two steps.
Talk about the team first,
and then the user second.
So the first thing we knew
was going to be super, super
critical for our data team
in particular to accomplish
its goals was going
to be finding a way
to minimize the friction it took
to get new data in particular
in the warehouse.
This was something that
was a huge problem for us
as our company went from
being a company that
made list posts that
lived on a website,
to suddenly being a
company that was publishing
across a bunch of
different platforms
and had content living
in all different places.
Every time we needed
to upload new data
before we had BigQuery, it was
this very, very laborious task
for us, where we were
writing new tables schemas,
writing migrations, bothering
people for backfill.
And that was something
that just didn't work.
So when we set out into our
adventure of moving everything
over into a BigQuery,
that was one
of the things that was
most important to us
during the build out.
So there were a couple of things
that we did in terms of the way
that we architected
the system that
have proven to be super,
super important for us
and allowed us to move
much more quickly than we
were in the past.
So the first one is that
all of our pipeline data
just goes straight into GCS.
Seems like kind of a
simple face value thing,
but it's actually
super important,
because what that
means is that we
don't have to do any
work as a data team
to get stuff into the place that
it needs to be for us to get it
into BigQuery.
If it passes through the
pipeline, it's there.
The second one was
that all it required
for us to actually import
data is writing a JSON schema.
So previously, like I said, we
had to write these migrations,
we had to bother
people for backfill.
Now, all of that's built in.
All you do is write a config
for what you want your table
to look like.
You deploy that,
your data is there.
You can deploy those tables
at any time with a review
from your teammate.
You're not blocked by the
data engineering team.
And you get your
backfill for free,
which is something that was
super, super crucial for us.
All you do is write
in a start date.
As long as the log
files are there,
you'll get that data back to
whatever start date you set.
So this has been huge for
us, and it's totally changed
the way that we think
about our workflow
and actually getting the data
that we need into our system
so that we can surface
it to our end users.
So once we've done that, we've
got a couple of other things
that were super important.
And the biggest one
of these was actually
giving analysts
and data scientists
the tools they need to build
for less technical users.
So we had taken a
philosophy in the past
where we had actually built
a lot of stuff in house.
And when we were
just a publisher that
made list content that
lived on the website,
like I said earlier, that
actually served us really well,
because we had something that
was custom built to our needs.
But it didn't scale very well.
As soon as we started publishing
on all these other platforms,
it became a really,
really big burden for us
to find a way to incorporate
that new stuff into dashboards,
because we were suddenly
relying on our engineering team
to help us do the whole process
of how do we redesign this,
how do we do this whole thing.
So we knew we needed a better
system that would allow
us to iterate more quickly.
Like I said, this is sort
of the core of the way we
think about everything we do.
We really want to be able
to power that feedback
loop for our content creators.
So what we ultimately
landed on was
that we needed to use
a third party solution,
and the one that we
picked was Looker.
I'm sure some of you guys
are familiar with Looker,
and I'm talking talk
a little bit more
about why it works for us,
and why it might work for you.
So why did we choose Looker?
Like I said, one of the
biggest things that we found
was going to be huge for us
was the minimal dev overhead.
You do need to have a
little bit of maintenance
at the initial setup.
But once that's
sort of in place,
your data team can actually
do a lot of the heavy lifting,
because Looker manages
a lot of the front end.
And you're really just sort
of managing the data modeling
piece, which is
something that most data
teams can do on their own.
The second thing that worked
really, really well for us--
and keep in mind those
sort of varying skill sets
that I mentioned earlier when
I was talking about this--
is that it can support both a
general and specific use case.
So what does that actually mean?
Looker actually has
created different versions
of their experience
for people who
have different levels of
comfort working with data.
So they call this explorer
versus dashboards.
There are sort of different
ways that you can think
about what that actually means.
This example that you're
seeing here is a dashboard.
So this is a very
curated experience
that someone who's a little
less comfortable working
with raw data might see.
This is actually a real
dashboard that we have.
This is showing you
completions and results
for a specific quiz.
So if you're someone
who's writing quizzes
for BuzzFeed.com,
you want to come in,
you want to see what
results people are
getting, what they're choosing
for different questions.
We actually are able to
serve this all right to you
in a very curated Looker
experience where all
you have to do is put in a URL.
So we're taking a lot of the
burden off of the end user
in terms of having to understand
how that data is structured,
where it comes from, how to
pull it, how to manipulate it.
They get the answers that
they need super quickly.
But we can also support a
much more specific use case
for someone like an
analyst, maybe someone
on our finance team.
So Looker calls this explore.
The way that it looks
is it's essentially
a big pivot table
that sits right
on top of your data warehouse.
You have someone on your
more technical data team
that comes in and sets
up the modeling layer,
which will define the
dimensions and the measures
and how those things
are aggregated.
It's all SQL based.
It's a language
called LookML that's
kind of a weird hybrid
between YAML and SQL.
But it's pretty
easy to work with,
and it allows us to support
these more specific use cases.
So let's say our finance
team wants to come in here
and cut stuff up by months
and countries and all sorts
of different things that
most users don't need.
They have access to do that
stuff right here in the tool.
And this is actually
the explorer
that undergirds this dashboard
I just showed you guys.
So you can see how the
two things sort of connect
to each other.
There were a couple
of other things
that we found worked
really well for us when
we were looking at Looker
and a bunch of other tools.
One of the other
key ones was that it
has tons of off-the-shelf
access controls.
So this was important for
us for a couple of reasons.
First of all, we
have users that are
working across these
different platforms.
Some people might work on,
say, Facebook and YouTube.
But you might have
some people who
work on just Snapchat,
or just Instagram.
And one of the things
that we found early on
is that it was very confusing
and overwhelming for them
to be able to see just
everything if that's not
what they needed.
So this allowed us to sort of
partition off the experience,
and make it a little
bit more digestible
by only showing people the
things that they wanted to see,
or they needed to see.
Similarly, you could
imagine that's become
very useful if you
have sensitive data
in your instance.
So the ways that a lot
of other people use this
is that if they have, say,
revenue data or finance
data that they only want
specific teams to be
able to see, you can kind
of use it in the same way.
We've done that a
little bit, but it's
something that's sort of
less important for the way
that we think about
how this data surfaced.
We really like to democratize
and make most things
available to most people.
Another thing that's great
is that it's actually
version controlled, so it's
connected directly to Git.
This is super helpful
for the modeling layer.
It's also extremely helpful
when something breaks,
and you're trying to
figure out what happened.
You can actually chase it
back to a specific commit.
This has also been really
helpful because we're
relying pretty heavily
on a functionality
that Looker has
it's called PDTs--
Persistent Derived Tables.
So what it allows
you to do is kind
of create your own
on-the-fly aggregations that
run on schedule and are cached.
So if you, say, have
hourly data that you
want to roll up
daily or monthly,
you can actually do
this right in Looker.
It's all version controlled.
You can sort of see how
those aggregations are
working, how they're changing.
It's something that's worked
really well for us-- so much so
that we're actually
starting to steal it
into one of our own features,
which I'll talk about
in a little bit.
And then it's also been a
great prototyping ground.
So we still have
our homebuilt tools.
We still rely on those
a bunch, sort of as
the front page for the
way that a lot of people
experience data, with
Looker being the deeper use
case that they have.
So this has been a
great place for us
to sort of test out
new data experiences
that we want to make
available to people,
and potentially integrate
into our existing tools.
Which is actually
something you can
see we've done with that same
quiz data that I showed you.
So now we have this
tool called Dashbird.
This was the old dashboard
that I showed you
about that was
created originally
to show post performance.
So we've now gone and taken that
more granular quiz performance
data and just
incorporated it directly
into the Dashbird experience
for all of our quizzes.
So this is something
that users really like.
It reduces the friction.
They can kind of see everything
they want in one place.
And getting data like that
into this experience previously
would have been
something that would
have required a lot more
work, a lot more effort,
a lot more dev hours.
So it's a way that
we've sort of been
able to reduce the lead time
on some of these things,
and also test much more quickly.
I think we would
have been much more
hesitant to build
something like that,
knowing that it would
have required so much dev
work previously.
And now we were able to kind
of just plop it right in there.
So I've talked a lot
about our data team.
And I want to talk a
little bit about the way
that we think about building
for our non-technical users,
because these are really the
people that are most important,
and they're on the front lines.
So this boils down to
sort of four things
that we've found
in our experience
in the many iterations of
building within Looker.
The first one-- and this is
actually a huge reason that we
chose BigQuery--
is that people want
answers really quickly.
We sort of were the architects
of our own demise in the sense
that we had been very
thoughtful about the way
that we had engineered a
lot of our homebuilt tools.
So people were used to things
loading really, really quickly.
So when we suddenly put
them in an environment
where they were hitting a data
warehouse rather than, say,
[INAUDIBLE] or Redis cache.
They were like, why is this
taking so long to load?
I'm used to, like, two
seconds, and suddenly I'm
waiting two minutes for things.
So BigQuery was a way
for us to alleviate
a lot of those problems,
create an experience
that was much faster and
much more attuned to what
people were used to.
Particularly when you consider
that a lot of these people
are non-technical,
and their eyes kind of
glaze over when you
start explaining
to them that the reason
that the thing is slow
is not because they
did something wrong,
or you did something
wrong, but just
because the warehouse
is taking a long time,
or maybe it has a BigQuery
backlog right now.
So that's a place where
BigQuery has helped us a lot.
Another thing we've
found, and I sort of
alluded to this earlier,
is that less is more.
When we first started
working with Looker,
we sort of were
like, oh my god, we
can suddenly open up the
whole warehouse to everybody.
This is so great.
And that actually was
really bad because people
got into this
experience, and they
were like, I don't know what
any of this stuff means.
Why are there six
different view metrics?
I don't understand
the difference
between a time series.
Why does this number not
change at all when I add dates?
So we've really reeled back
a lot of that stuff, tried
to simplify.
Really tried to show people
sort of the bare minimum
of what they need
as a starting point,
and then scale up from there,
rather than starting off
by opening up the floodgates.
To that same point, clearly
labeled and described
fields are everything.
We made a huge mistake
early on of relying
on less technical
users to understand,
oh, this is an aggregate,
this is not an aggregate.
It just was a big mistake, and
we actually lost a lot of trust
that it took us a little
while to build back.
So this is something that I
can't emphasize highly enough.
And as we've worked through
a lot of these challenges,
we've actually impose
a very strict style
guide on our
technical users that
is requiring them to do
a lot of these things
because of how important
we found it to be.
And then the last
piece, in tune to what
I showed you guys
on the last slide.
We've really tried not to
fight existing work flows
if we don't have to.
So if users already have a tool
that they're used to going to,
if there's a way for
you to sort of integrate
the different things
you're doing together,
that's something that we've
found works super, super well.
So now that I've walked you
guys through all of this,
where has it actually gotten us?
Where are we today?
So this is our usage as
of a couple of weeks ago.
So we have hundreds
of terabytes of data
across 300-plus tables
accessible to our analysts
and our users via BigQuery.
I've been told that
we actually are just
starting to cross into
petabytes territory now,
with some of the new stuff
that we've been importing.
We're running over
100,000 queries a day.
So bear in mind I've
talked a lot about Looker
and supporting our
non-technical users,
but BigQuery is
also supporting all
of our different
technical use cases.
So our machine learning models,
all of the sort of regularly
scheduled jobs.
So you can see
Looker is actually
is only about 5% to 10% of
our total workflow in a day,
but we're really relying
on BigQuery super
heavily for all
of our data needs.
And then one of the things that
we're actually super proud of
is that we have more than half
of our 1,500 employees using
Looker each month, which I think
really speaks to what we've
been able to accomplish here,
especially when you consider
the fact that most
of those users
are people that are not used
to interacting with a BI tool,
and are usually content
creators, writers, editors,
that sort of thing.
So a little bit in terms
of what's next for us.
We're starting to
experiment with a new tool
that you guys are going to hear
more about today and tomorrow.
We were one of the early access
partners for BigQuery Machine
Learning.
This is something that we're
really excited about because it
allows us to really
open up machine learning
to a lot more of our analysts,
whereas previously there
were much more stringent
technical requirements
in terms of who can
do that type of work.
This is also something that's
been developed in partnership
with Looker, which is
really cool for us,
because it allows us
to sort of just plug
in and see some things, like our
model performance statistics,
right in the Looker experience
that we're used to using.
To that end, we're
actually continuing
to expand pretty heavily on
our existing recommendation
systems.
So this is something
that actually
powers a lot of what you
see on the BuzzFeed site,
and even what you see
on our Facebook pages.
It's all happening
behind the scenes,
but it's stuff that you
might not realize is there.
So it's the way that
we optimize our feeds.
This is the way that
we're recommending
content to our
social media editors
to post on our different
Facebook pages.
We have about 140
of those, so you
can imagine that that gets to
be a pretty complicated problem
for them.
So this is the place where
we're investing heavily.
And our use of GCP
and BigQuery has
allowed us to really reduce
a lot of the friction
there and move
much more quickly.
And then we're also working
on our own materialized view
solution.
So we actually just finished
our version 1 launch of this,
and are starting to
launch on version 2.
So this is the solution
that's akin to Looker's
persistent derived
table solution.
So we really liked
the idea of being
able to have cached aggregations
that we could access,
but what we didn't like was
having that locked specifically
into Looker, because
we were running
into these scenarios where, say,
a data scientist was working
on a model, and wanted to
access our denormalized Facebook
statistics.
And that was only in Looker.
And suddenly you're
hitting Looker API,
and then having to do all
this additional manipulation.
So what we decided to do was
actually build our own solution
for this.
And our data engineering
team-- again,
is sitting right
there-- has been
so great through this process.
And I personally, as
a big user of this,
could not be more thrilled with
the way that it's turned out.
But this is something
that we think
is going to be
really crucial for us
in terms of upping our game in
terms of our data governance,
having really consistent ways
that we think about cleaning up
our data, aggregating our data.
So this is actually
a bit of the work
that I'm sort of most
excited about right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]